i don't want to move on from this but i
really did want to ask you about carmen
san diego
because bringing back properties
is exciting gives us the opportunity to
recapture
what people loved before but also adapt
them for modern audiences and you've
kind of already done that
with that property so what would you say
i guess are your
unique goals for the live action uh
feature instead dwayne who did the
animation um was
is brilliant is and i don't was is just
because we finished but
is brilliant is a brilliant man and did
such a phenomenal job at creating this
world because we know carmen i mean i
grew up with carmen santiago
and it was mostly like the pbs game and
it was mostly like
the computer game but you didn't really
know anything about her
so dwayne created this entire and
incredibly
intertwined beautiful story with
backstory and all that
and so for with the live action to try
you know ideally we would be able to
create
multiple films but to bring in this
first
film it is really imperative to
us to create this iconic character that
we loved
right that we didn't know much about and
give her a really
solid story that we all fall in love
with
so that's the unique challenge that
we are working on but i'm really excited
and hopeful because
it's coming together great